what is the best way to learn a job in
cloud and it now this is a question I
get asked all the time in my comments
section ever since I started this
YouTube channel 3 years ago having gone
through this process myself from
studying Information Systems in
University to spending two years at AWS
as a Solutions architect I know just how
hard it can be to figure out where to
start and everyone's journey is
different right you might be fresh out
of school looking to switch career paths
or perhaps to just curious about it and
want to dive into something new which is
why in this video I'd like to share with
you something I wish I came across Ross
earlier in my tech Journey the Google It
support professional certificate this is
a program designed by Google provided by
corsera that offers a comprehensive
Pathway to understand the fundamentals
of it no prior knowledge is required and
by the end of the program you'll be
equipped with the skills needed for an
entry-level it job now this video is
sponsored by corera so a big thank you
to them for allowing me to provide my
honest review but before we dive further
into the certificate let's understand
why it skills are so in demand and will
continue to be sought after for years to
to come in today's Digital World
technology is at the center of
everything we do from every app we use
to every online transaction we make we
heavily rely on it systems to run
smoothly in fact it's estimated that
tens of millions of it related jobs are
being generated worldwide and just in
the us alone there were 4.1 million Tech
job openings last year with advancements
in areas like Cloud Ai and cyber
security the it landscape will continue
to grow and evolve this means that
demand for people with it skills isn't
just going to be a temporary trend it's
something that will continue to rise in
popularity now you might be asking what
does an IT professional actually do well
it at its core is all about solving
problems this could involve fixing
network issues safeguarding important
company data or just making sure
software is kept up to date people who
work in it are pretty much the backbone
of every modern business they work hand
inand with different departments in the
company to make sure that the tech
infrastructure is not only up and
running but is also secure and efficient
and so this is where the Google It
support professional certific ifate
comes into play it's an online program
designed for anyone looking to learn
more about it and build the right skills
to get hired into an entry level role
it's 100% online making it super
flexible and easy to tune into it's also
self-paced meaning you can learn at your
own speed you can see here that there's
over 1.3 million students that have
enrolled and the course has a 4.8 star
rating now I know here that it says it
takes 6 months if you spend 10 hours a
week but if you're like me and also like
to watch things in two time speed you
might be able to complete it much faster
another bonus is that this program is
pretty well known in the tech community
so when you add it to your resume or
LinkedIn profile it can help you stand
out to potential employers okay let's
take a look at what the Google It
support professional certificate
actually covers this is a five course
series and each course aims to teach you
a different side of it the first course
starts off with the fundamentals of tech
support and then goes into other topics
like computer networking operating
systems systems Administration and it
security as I went through each of the
courses I found that the videos not only
provided me with very detailed
explanations but we also very fun and
engaging to watch instead of just
throwing facts and figures at you the
content is aligned with real world it
challenges that companies face which
means that once you complete it you'll
be equipped with skills that you can
apply directly to your next it job for
example throughout the courses you'll
learn how to perform day-to-day it
support tasks how to provide endtoend
customer support and how to use systems
like Linux and the command line
interface they also have quizzes and
Hands-On labs to test your understanding
so this will help solidify your
knowledge on topics and increase your
confidence something else I wanted to
highlight is that this program prepares
you for the comp tier A+ exams which if
you don't already know is the industry
standard certification for it now on to
the most important question for the
video is the Google IT professional
certificate worth your time and energy
my honest opinion is yes and no one
major advantage of this program is that
it offers training designed by Google
one of the largest tech Giants in the
world this means you'll be learning from
Google employees who have used these it
foundations to launch their own careers
another benefit is how flexible the
program is even with a pack schedule
dedicating just 10 hours a week can get
you an industry recognized certificant
in 6 months time and while doing so
you're preparing yourself for an
entry-level job in it on the cost side
of things taking this program can save
you a significant amount of money
especially compared to the more
traditional routes like boot camps or
intensive courses the Google IT
professional certificate on corsera
offers a 7-Day free trial to start with
and after that it's $39 per month how
however just like every other learning
free source it's not suitable for
everyone this certificate focuses on
covering it foundations so if you
already have years of experience working
in it it might be better to go for
something more advanced or more
specialized another reason it might not
be right for you is if you're not ready
to commit and put in the hours truly
needed to understand the content for
example if you're deciding between
different career paths and not sure if
it is right for you then it might be
good to do a bit more exploration before
diving straight into the program but
yeah overall I believe the Google it
support professional certificate on
corsera is a great way to learn and
build your foundations in order to start
a career in it it offers a structured
learning path and covers the fundamental
concepts so that by the end of it you'll
walk away with a certificate that you
can add on to your resume as I mentioned
there's a 7-Day free trial available for
the certificate so head to the link in
the description below if you're
interested all right so this brings us
to the end of the video please let me
know your thoughts in the comments below
and if you end up enrolling I'd love to
hear how it goes thanks so much for
watching and I'll see you soon bye for
now